but guess we'll see about that
all right now we're gonna go through
kind what Jax has to start the common
moves and as always he's got a ground
pound note that you can also you can
look at all variation splits or two you
you can also push it far away which I've
missed with obviously yeah so you could
do all this gralton pounds in this
variation in different distances right
now somebody other grab half later will
change grande get to that also he has
what everybody loves about Jax
that's the Superman punch right arrow
and something that I love about this
punch now is you can actually turn it
into an overhead by pushing down during
the middle of and get out of the house
so you can actually like if you're
ducking for instance okay pretty fun
duck so I can hey there we go see he
also has live got to grab has to have
everyone loves to got to grab nothing
like just getting punched in the face
repeatedly oh we push this button clicks
I can remember the rest and now I do
good practice so we got rockets and it
can be helped
no you can delay it I can delay like
also cancel out of it obviously
machine-gun and you can point that
machine gun upwards yeah all right
probably more damage you can also exit
if you'd lie kinda meter when we grab
some meter there we go do again okay I
just good so universal most part I'm
definitely more babe so you get those
zoning tools absolutely along with this
traditional Jax moves right and one
thing that I am super proud of we get to
meet her here good bro that's a
wrestling fan he has a powerbomb
powerbomb into a some sort of a
wheelbarrow suplex you're speaking a
foreign language Justin right now so
there we go so that is def Jack's in a
nutshell with his uh you know it's heavy
weapons variation cool let's move and
pick character select and uh I love
heavy weapons I do love that variation
but you know me Derek what do I like to
do when I do love - graphic
he is a grappling madman I love
grappling so this is what he has two
variations that are kind of grapple
heavy okay so a good idea let's do some
cannon and go with Sonya Blade good big
stage oh thank you you're so kind of me
I did by accident oh well I'm gonna pick
my own good at 50/50 all right destroyed
City and jungle thank you now this
Jack's is really interesting cuz there's
a lot of some awesome throws he has
things have come back from older games
and you'll notice his variation visuals
is the glowing arm yeah different colors
of armor yeah so here we go I'm not
rejoining Special Forces not even to
protect Jackie leave her out of this you
don't also make the other character like
doing thank you this is like our eighth
ninth tenth whatever show so I'm kind of
picking up on what to do right right
right so first of all he has a command
grab okay so there's the regular version
you can also are you gonna be able to do
it like this oh so the first version you
can actually hit another button to make
it do another slam uh-huh if you exit
I'm gonna do up to four slam four slams
it is a quad slam you can get three
pretty easy the fourth one is kind of
for all you pros out there to really do
some hardcore trolling so it's like the
tournament hype super turbine hype if
you do it 1% more damage 1% but you got
it all but you've got only one frame or
whatever it's a yes right I've done a
few times if happy I have have you can
ask anyone
Danny left Jen she wasn't there okay
I've been final if I can pull it off
here it's doing the behind smoke let's
see it that's absolutely the complete
give me three tries three trucks where
does that even not nice with me - okay
all right
not you you were just beating the other
two sorry all right let's go one more
try one more one more
okay Tyler you gotta walk away I have to
and it's awesome I think up to three
pretty easily glad to be practicing with
Jack so where's characters another thing
you have that I love is back is he has
this oh he's got the guy to grab in the
air yeah so he can go in the jack for me
yep let's let's time this say one two
three
there we go Sam back breakers back okay
you also like you always were able to
you neighbors like I did a second ago
you can jump into it but not like that
right no you're doing really good at
showing us throw right thank you
everybody loves it so he also has some
really cool inside of combo throws okay
which we really fun mix ups to do you
can do this
oh alright and then you can do a higher
one you can do this and those you have
to get have them in different ways so
it's gonna be interesting for them for
the employer to figure out how that
works
sure okay so that is a best wrestler Jax
he still has this is still directional
of course we get the one that isn't a
little bit like you mean the next month
the next one or okay we have that many
oh yeah so that is that's wrestler
Jack's big fan of him Jack's easily
looks awesome what do you think of
Jack's I'm not really good at okay so
that is three tiers of the quad grab huh
wow that was hype as hell yeah I enjoy
Jack's a lot you know I'm not a grappler
I'm gonna like that in your face
pressure glare I I have a no no patience
for fair yeah
also we announced just recently and now
it's out the MKX mobile game is out oh
yes download it today so when you get
your console game when you link them
together there are certain things you
can get yeah go to WB play yes I know
WBA you had at W ID at one point the
name has change it's still all the same
thing cool um I've tested it I have seen
the rating skin everything is working
there it's gonna be awesome and one
thing that I've noticed is people are
like hey I signed up my wbd account and
I didn't get farmer Jack's
and ninja mine we have to work for him
to it's not just login and we give you
free stuff rate
yours yes otherwise gonna do some new
little work on both sides not work
we're playing a game it's playing and
it's a free game right so can we have
farmer Jack's will kind of show the last
one with him huh okay maybe we'll show a
fidelity whoo all right I'm gonna find
Johnny Cage I know he's somewhere on
this either in the bottom oh there is
he's just like an old Buddhist there so
you know it's hard to recognize them
max yeah mmm
graham Snape select destroyed safe I've
said before I love the farmer Jack's
because it's like all of my relatives
they're all they're all farmers in
northern Kansas so that is immediately
that's kind of how hydrants do sometimes
so well the flannels absolutely
absolutely overalls not quite yet
thought you could use a workout are you
busy making another shitty movie yeah
all right so this is the Pumped Up
variety now this one you're really cool
his gotcha grab is now you can push
different buttons to do different
attacks get out of that bug do this I
can do that I can go to the head then
take a crush the skull face do that do
that right and also very interesting for
the kind of the higher level players
you'll notice is twelve vernier okay
okay if I do the Gacha grab most
versions of it will knock you down this
one nagging is you form or mix-ups
oh I also forgot something that Jax has
in two of them what big-time
oh you mean that came back oh yeah and
also when my favorite parts of it you
can oh yeah awesome can't cancel Avenue
but you can hold it so so that that's
really cool you can pull this off right
there
and you know I think like would be kind
of embarrassing is if somebody just
grabs you for the last hit in a hole to
that mmm way I would just be pissed but
you like just punch me
the computers done that tornado yeah so
this thing would lost the computer will
never never happen so this version he
has a ground town as well right this is
everywhere we're like an earthquake an
earthquake yeah and also from the air so
this this is all about pure power with
it and it's kind of like a whole bunch
of the previous Jack's and it's just
based in each one of the variations
right which is awesome so I this um this
is where the ones I use a lot I of
course use Ressler right if you have
wrestle arm I do like wrestlers BAM and
then you can you know he's got some
great stuff here he's got a nice low
that you can go right into the gotcha
awesome so you turn my head into an
ashtray
no smoking after my little t-rex arms
that actually is called t-rex or